depression anxiety addiction mental
disorders that involve a rigidity of
thought what psychedelics appear to do
is break those habits of thought what is
the cost of this though it's a great
question
one of the 100 most influential people
in the world please welcome michael
pollan
you've written six new york times
bestsellers
and they're on such a diverse range of
topics two of the topics i've worked on
have turned into movements i was writing
a piece on the meat industry and how
[ __ ] up it is and it led to this
movement to try to reform agriculture
then i got into psychedelics
they're much better than the results for
antidepressants when they came on the
scene and we're talking about potential
cures not simply symptoms there are
risks with this and we don't talk about
them nearly enough and people are going
to get hurt
one of the immersive journalistic
pursuits you embarked on was this topic
of caffeine it allows us to function
better it allows us to work harder
longer you're feeling the clearing of
the mental fog i can tell you the cost
of doing heroin every day but no one can
seem to tell me the cost of having three
cups of coffee a day if you really want
to understand your relationship to this
drug you have to
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
diary of a ceo usa edition i hope
nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
michael i have to say it's a real a huge
honor to speak to you when i departed
from my company and i started
investigating what i was interested in
one of the things alongside djing and
this podcast and many others was
psychedelics i was so compelled by
um this apparent and i didn't have
confirmation this apparent increase in
mental health disorders in my country
in the uk as you know as i know you've
talked about many times it's the suicide
is the single biggest killer of men
under the age of 45. and i thought that
the most sort of
fulfilling thing i could do with the
next chapter of my life was start a
company in that space that's how i came
to the psychedelics industry that's how
i came to actually work in the
psychedelics industry and when i arrived
in that industry people said your name
over and over and over again and they
told me and i'm not blowing smoke up
your ass they told me that i had to it
was like
i wasn't allowed in the industry until
i'd read your book right
um how to change your mind it was that
much of a pivotal book for my colleagues
at the time
you've written six new york times
bestsellers
and they're on such a diverse range of
topics to be so successful in such a
diverse range of topics in writing my
first question to you that i wanted to
ask is
as you look back on your life in your
career
why were you successful
what was it about you that made you
successful
i think finding the right topics i i had
a nose for topics that most people
weren't paying attention to i felt very
lucky i was writing in these
uncompetitive spaces nobody was writing
about psychedelics except you know the
small handful of people within the
psychedelic community who write these
books for one another that nobody else
reads and they and
so i had i i remember thinking the whole
time i was writing that book is like
where is everybody am i making mistake
here investing so much in this
no one else is writing about it and the
same was true with food there was very
when i started writing about food and
agriculture very little being written so
a willingness to go into places that
other people you know weren't working in
i don't like writing in competitive
environments i'm not fast enough
so that was one thing
um
i think there's something about the way
i structure stories
so i don't start on page one with all
the answers and if you read the first
page of anything i've written i'm kind
of an idiot on page one
um i've got questions i don't have
answers
and so my books are kind of detective
stories or you know i just tell about
the process of my figuring things out
and going to this person and learning
this and having this experience and
learning that
and i think that readers don't like to
be lectured at and um and i don't do
that i i take them along on the journey
when i think about starting a business
one of the pieces of advice that um i
would and i think a lot of entrepreneurs
would give a young aspiring entrepreneur
is to not pursue something that you're
not genuinely interested about because
oh yeah
without question i mean that i write
about things that i'm passionate about
curiosity is the driver and cultivating
curiosity doesn't necessarily come
naturally to everybody it's a muscle you
have to cultivate and you have to see
the world in terms of questions rather
than answers
because questions are always more
interesting than answers
so i do cultivate that when i see
something happening i remember when i
first read a little article in the new
york times saying they were giving
psilocybin to cancer patients to help
them deal with their fear of death i'm
like what's that about why would you do
that why would you ever want to take a
trip when you got a terminal diagnosis
i don't think i would want to do that
you know i just had all these questions
and the only way to answer them was to
do
reporting was to go interview the
patients and interview the doctors
and
satisfy my curiosity so without question
i i can't write about things i'm not
interested in i mean i get you know you
as you can imagine editors are always
coming to me we would like an article on
this or a book on this and i'm like
i don't feel it so yeah so you do have
to you do have to care about it i mean
writing a book is such a long journey
with so many twists and turns and um so
if you if you don't have some
deep-seated drive
to understand something to tell a story
you're gonna
good chance you're gonna sink along the
way
and you really do
go all the way that's something that
you're well immersion is a big part of
my work and i think and i think that's
another that's been another key thing i
can you know i've been thinking about
this a lot recently um
but i can trace the moment where i was
first exposed to the kind of journalism
that i think of myself as doing and that
was when i was 13 my parents gave me a a
book called paper lion so book of sports
writing was about football by a writer
named george plimpton
he was a literary person but a sports
writer too and loved sports writing and
um
he was kind of bored with how sports
writing was done then which is you know
it's that cynical cigar chomping guy on
the sidelines with the hat who just been
there done that seen it all has no sense
of wonder or excitement anymore and he
thought there's a way to reinvent this
form
and he and what he did was he persuaded
the detroit lions
american football team
to let him
train with them over the summer summer
training camp and then start
in a exhibition game at the beginning of
the season
as quarterback so this guy had never
played professional sports at all um was
not an athlete and there he was um
facing this line of giant guys coming at
him
and he could write about football in a
way that no sports writer could but
neither any football player could
because they had been doing it since
they were 10 or 6
and they no longer saw it freshly it was
a job
but he had this incredible sense of
wonder and humor because he's a fish out
of water and it opened up all these
funny narrative possibilities
and
i realized that book
just sat with me i loved that book so
when i started writing
i forget which book it was in
i really i think it was my second book
was a book about architecture and then i
realized i couldn't write this book
unless i built something myself
and so finding how to put my finding the
way to put myself in the story
is uh been key for me
and with agriculture you know i bought a
cow and followed them through the food
system
um you bought a cow i did i i was
writing a piece uh that became a chapter
in the omnivore's dilemma
on the meat industry and how [ __ ] up
it is and um and feedlots and and the
drugs they give the animals
and that was my assignment from the new
york times and i found this
and i was going to do the piece in terms
of i was going to follow one animal
through the whole system from
insemination to slaughter
and um this was a piece called power
steer that was published in the new york
times
and you it's on my website if you want
to um check it out for free but along
the way that one of the ranchers said if
you really want to understand our
business you should buy one of these
animals and i thought immediately this
is a great idea
because it's going to do two things it's
going to give me a character even though
it's an animal
um which you know having an animal hero
and a piece is always a good thing
and it's going to give me a different
kind of access when i get to the feedlot
and the slaughterhouse because i own
this animal i'm not just a journalist
and so i picked out this animal number
534
um
and i followed him and i you know i met
him on the ranch where he was born and
then i had a reunion with him in the
feedlot where he ended up you know
several months later
i'm super intrigued by what happened to
this cow oh yeah well
were you emotionally attached to it at
all when that when it got you know
reached its end of its days i was a
little i didn't they wouldn't
something happened so i had to publish
the piece before he was slaughtered
right
he was slo uh they wanted to publish the
piece i handed it in in february they
wanted to publish it in march and he
wasn't going to get slaughtered till
june i wanted to wait
because i still had very good access
because nobody knew i was writing an
expose on the on the meat industry i was
just some goofball following the life of
this cow
and um
but when the piece came out the
slaughterhouse is like we're not doing
business with pollen anymore um
and uh so i was hoping to retrieve the
steaks and eat them or or try to eat
them and see what i thought about it and
um but they wouldn't they wouldn't play
anymore
um
and it's interesting when this piece
came out
there was a whole uh explosion in the
american media
of people who wanted to save the cow
because they knew he hadn't been killed
yet
and i had people i had someone in uh
write me a
movie producer
in beverly hills wrote and say i want to
buy your your 534 and i said what are
you going to do with it i'm going to put
it on my front lawn
and
i was like
you know
saving one animal is not going to fix
the food system and everybody thought
that way there was even a telethon
on a vegan radio station in new jersey
they were raising money and they would
pay me anything i wanted for this animal
and i'm like this is not
this is you know this is not how you
change the meat system by like having
this poster boy steer
and they actually likened it to the
underground railroad that's saving one
slave
was worth it i was like that's
interesting
um
and uh so i did not sell it um
and it went through the process and
somebody ate it but it wasn't me
there's something
sort of telling about that about the
human condition where we believe that
one
sort of surface level act of
apparent is probably virtually signaling
but apparent goodness is
is
enough or we don't really care about the
systemic no systems are hard to deal
with right we're we're we evolved to
deal with individuals and stories of
individuals and that's why this story
was powerful because it was about an
individual cow
but what matters is the system this you
know i i chose it because it was
representative of the system it was a
very typical animal going through a
typical
start out on grass
kind of idyllic situation in in
south dakota move on to this horrible
feedlot where they stand in their own
manure all day and eat corn which makes
them sick and they have to take drugs
and then they go through this
slaughterhouse process
and which i described even though i
didn't get to witness but
i think we have trouble dealing with
systems
and so we we we always have the poster
child you know i mean you look how you
know look at all the um non-profits how
they advertise right there's one animal
or there's one child that you're gonna
save with your donation and uh i just
think it's a limitation of our
imagination that's what i was thinking
of a very recent example of that which
is the tragic death of george floyd and
how that sparked people around the world
specifically on instagram posting a
black tile
as a black male i looked at that and
thought this is like the easy thing to
do right but it doesn't solve the
systemic issues of sort of race and race
relations and discrimination but like we
can all do the like virtue signaling
socially
whatever black tile but again that the
complexity of the system below it that's
kind of cool might be the cause of some
of these things is just
does anybody really care to deal with
that you know it's like i think it's
just overwhelming to people
and
you know i don't i mean it is virtue
signaling i mean all over berkeley where
i live people still have black lives
matter signs in their windows you know
everywhere like when are they going to
take them down
are they ever going to take them down
i understand the value of expressing
that point of view but
there's so much more that needs to be
done what does need to be done when
we're thinking about sort of rewiring
systems
is it education is it political is it
i tend to think it's about law
i think you can't
legislate morality but you can change
laws and make certain kinds of
activity discrimination illegal
you know we're approaching it in america
at the level of everyone's soul
we're trying to reform everyone's soul
with anti-racism campaigns and things
like that we'll see if it works
i tend to think it doesn't work um and
one of the things that i've been very
discouraged by is the collapse and
support for black lives matter which had
majority support after that george floyd
summer and now it doesn't it's been
politicized right
yeah and it's been fought against by
republicans and
but i also think
shaming people is not the way to get
them to change men
and there was a lot of that and
and i see a lot of this on college
campuses i see a lot of this throughout
the culture i understand the instinct
but i think you get i think you invite a
backlash um
that's not the best way to get people to
change and i think in fact it can have
the opposite effect i think
from what i've observed specifically
around the issue of black lives matter
that shame that i saw in the wake of
george floyd's death only resulted in
this kind of like apparent social
compliance not change like okay now i
have to pretend to be this person and
that like compliance again is not what
we're looking for i did a big tweet
thread about how i felt white people
were being shamed into either speaking
out saying something profound or or
other when really
it for me it was actually a ver the
least natural reaction to the scenes
that i saw in that video of george
floyd's death would be
right doing a tweet or posting i even i
spent weeks like processing it and then
i was being shamed steve why aren't you
speaking up for black people and i just
thought you know like
you know and all of that again it made
me
it made it didn't bring me closer to
waving the flags it just made me feel
like
i don't know kind of disillusioned by it
all
so you're right shane
yeah there was a lot of pressure to
immediately express your solidarity yeah
the black lives matter and and if you
didn't there was something wrong yeah
yeah i definitely saw a lot of that
um i don't know i just think we need i
think our politics has to be organized
around um more positive emotions i mean
make people feel really good about
social change about um
and
i think you know really concrete i think
the way we hire people needs to change i
think the way we promote people needs to
change i think i think that there's
certain still certain kinds of
discrimination that have to be outlawed
i mean the biggest thing going on at the
same time of black lives matter is
taking away the ability of african
americans to vote
you know voter suppression that is so
concrete and you need those votes in
order to change things and
so while we're working on you know our
souls we're losing the franchise which
you know the civil rights movement has
fought long and hard um it's we're going
backwards
so um
i think it's i think we should consider
whether this politics is working or not
um and i i would suggest it might not be
i would agree um
we started talking about the topic of
like immersive journalism one of the
one of the sort of uh immersive
journalistic pursuits you embarked on
was this topic of caffeine
which i found really really interesting
because i believe there's a cost to
everything in life just generally and
the cost is always harder to see and
with caffeine in the culture
specifically in business and even i
could see it sort of taking hold in my
own life this topic of caffeine i'm like
people never talk about the cost of it
as if it's the super drug we take it it
just sends us out no freedom exactly
right so i and i started thinking with
anxiety on the rise is there is there a
risk that this sort of tampering with
our
um
our emotional state
is going to
ruin the system that regulates us
naturally and make us go up okay fine
when we take caffeine but then the down
like every other drug like heroin and
cocaine is going to be
equally um
destructive
yeah i mean
i you know you're talking about the law
of compensation i think is what ralph
waldo emerson called it
and that there is there's always some
compensating thing there is no free
lunch and um and that was a real issue
as people were trying to understand how
caffeine worked um because it seemed to
be a free lunch here was something with
zero calories that gave you more energy
caffeine works by
blocking the action of a
neurotransmitter a neuromodulator
technically called adenosine it's a
chemical that we all have in our bodies
that um over the course of the day the
levels rise
and it um
plugs into a certain receptor in the
brain that's all over the brain i think
it's other parts of the body too
and adenosine is your body's
signal to slow down get ready for sleep
it builds sleep pressure
um
and uh what caffeine does is it fits
exactly in the same receptor and hijacks
it basically blocks the adenosine from
getting to that receptor so the
adenosine is still in your body but it's
not acting on your brain because it
can't get into those receptors
when the caffeine leaves your system
which takes a while to do
all that adenosine that's been building
up
comes in and so you're more tired than
you were before so you have this kind of
rebound exhaustion
so you're really borrowing that energy
from the future rather than creating new
energy out of nothing
um it's still very useful under certain
circumstances i'm not a critic of
caffeine um
it might be my favorite drug um
and i've tried a whole bunch um and
it was immersive journalism in that
in this case i had to stop doing
something rather than doing something so
in how to change your mind i tried lsd
and psilocybin and 5 meow dmt and all
these things that were really scary and
hard
for me
but this was harder giving up caffeine
for three months um
really was a stretch
and but it was a really interesting
experiment and it taught me that there's
a great value in giving things up
temporarily
just to understand your relationship to
them understand your dependence on them
what was hardest about it
well there was the withdrawal which took
a few days and was very unpleasant i
felt like kind of muzzy-headed i felt
like this veil had fallen between me in
reality
uh things seemed less fresh less
immediate
i didn't have headache the headaches
that some people report and i didn't
have the flu-like symptoms but i didn't
feel myself and i was sluggish i
couldn't concentrate i couldn't write
for the first week
i just
i i said in the book i felt like an
unsharpened pencil i just didn't have it
you know it takes a certain amount of
ego strength to launch into a writing
project
or launch into it every day
and i just didn't have it and uh so i
was like i don't know i don't know if i
can do this for three months
after the first week or so i found my
way back that i could work but i still
didn't feel myself and and it began to
occur to me that how curious is that
because
what does that say if if i feel more
normal on this drug than off this drug
because i'm i'm through the withdrawal
period
but i came to see that my my normal
default consciousness was caffeinated
consciousness as it is for a great many
of us i mean 90 of people on earth have
a daily relationship with caffeine
whether it's in um
tea coffee soda chocolate um it's in a
lot of things you know you meet people
who say i i can't talk to you until i've
had a cup of coffee i you know i'm not
civil i can only read the paper you know
people just don't enter into social
relations till they have a cup of coffee
the reason is they're going through
withdrawal and they're cranky and they
know it
the amount of people probably in this
room now there's probably no 12 people
in this building and of them i think
probably 12 of them have had that drug
today yeah with this society as you've
said people saying i can't function i
can't have a conversation until i've had
what is the cost of this though because
i can tell you the cost of doing heroin
every day
or pretty much yeah this is subtler even
sugar i can tell you the cost of doing
having you know huge amounts of sugar
every day but no one can seem to tell me
the cost of having three cups of coffee
a day yeah
well
the costs
i mean if it depends on how it agrees
with you i mean for some people on three
cups a day they get pretty jittery um
and
it passes over from this very positive
feeling to this nervous feeling and
that's that's a cost
um i think the larger cost is to our
identity as animals
we were designed i think to have rhythms
as animals do that you know you wake up
when the sun comes up and you start
going to sleep when it gets dark and
that we were tied into these natural
cycles
dictated by light
um
and it broke that connection it broke
that temporal connection
and
so there may be some cost as species and
we struggle with sleep and sleep is a
huge deal and sleep is a you know
you need sleep to be healthy insane you
need it for your mental health and
coffee does damage your sleep
now i put a little asterisk next to that
because if you can stop
drinking it after that morning cup
you're gonna have very little in your
system when you go to sleep
but
a cup of coffee you drink at noon
a quarter of that caffeine will still be
circulating at midnight so it takes a
while to get out of your system
most of the caffeine researchers i
interviewed do not drink
coffee or tea
interesting i mean these are people who
understand sleep and the importance of
sleep and one of the benefits i didn't
mention one of the benefits of being off
coffee is i slept like a teenager it was
fantastic i had some great sleeps my
sort of logical mind when it understands
how other drugs impact us and the
withdrawals and how they impact our
rhythms our natural rhythms even think
like testosterone if you take too much
of it your body stops producing it if
you do if you have too many sleeping
pills your body struggles to sleep
without them so i reflect on coffee and
go
surely
i'm an idiot so don't take this as the
truth surely um if i have coffee every
day i'm gonna struggle to like
self-regulate
um my ups and downs and i and if my if
i'm forcing my body to go up then my
body will come down even further than it
would ordinarily or you'll take
something else to make it come down yes
and then i'll have to take a sleeping
pill or alcohol yeah yeah yeah so now
people do get into these cycles of of
coffee and alcohol
or tea and alcohol um
so yeah there i think there's always a
cost but i would say
historically there have been the
benefits have outweighed
the costs of i mean compared to other
drugs um
i think that
we've gained a lot and there's the whole
social aspect of coffee i mean the
coffee house scene in london was just so
vibrant and
you know the the uh
the insurance and lloyds of london began
in a coffee house and the london stock
exchange began in a coffee house and um
you know english literature was changed
by the rhythms of conversation in the
coffee house and it was this place where
the classes could mix in a way they
couldn't in the tavern or anywhere else
and you know you can make a case and i
try to in the book that the
enlightenment and the age of reason owed
a lot to caffeine
so i think it had a really positive
effect in that it got people who were
inebriated on alcohol all the time to
think clearly
and that was a big deal because i don't
think people realize how much alcohol
people drank um prior to 1650. it was
the safest thing you could drink because
the water was contaminated with disease
and people understood that that's how
you got plagued was you know using the
wrong water pump and things like that
alcohol the fermentation process and the
alcohol itself
disinfected water to some extent but not
as effectively as boiling it
and coffee and tea the first time we
boiled water to drink um so the the
countries that embraced coffee and tea
suddenly their public health was much
improved they had much lower rates of
disease so that was also a boon so there
are a lot of positives you talk about
the reason why why coffee is addictive
anyway from a pollination perspective
which i found really yeah i've said that
before yeah so that was one of the
interesting bits of research that i came
across um so like a lot of drugs that
plants produce it begins its life as a
pesticide
um
most of these alkaloids that we think
are so great whether it's cocaine or um
caffeine or
um oh god there's so many of them and
they're not creating me right now the
plants evolved these as chemicals that
would um
kill insects or discourage insects from
eating them
and then we found that they had
interesting effects on our brains if you
got the dose right and so caffeine was
designed
it kills insects at high doses it also
stops other plants from germinating
nearby so
you get more habitat if you if you if
your leaves contain caffeine and they
drop
um
but
the cleverness of plants is such that
some of them figured out that a really
low dose of caffeine in their nectar
would attract bees
and the
orange the citrus family does this
reliably so they've repurposed this
pesticide as an attractant because you
don't put pesticide in your nectar
that's where you attract insects
and
it turns out bees really like caffeine
and they will go preferentially to
flowers that offer them caffeine we
don't know if they get a buzz
but they do prefer it and
it
does for them what it does for us it
improves their memory they're more
likely to go back to the flower that
gave them caffeine than any other flower
and remember where it was they will also
work harder as um so they become better
workers basically so the plants are
manipulating the bees to do their
bidding we knew that but in a much
deeper way than we understood by
essentially you know drugging them and
then humans came along and then humans
yeah yeah but but the curious thing is
why should a pesticide have these mental
effects for us
and the theory i advance in the book is
that if you're
a plant and you're and you're bothered
by pests
the best strategy is not to kill the
pest
because if you do that if you just put
out a lethal chemical
you're going to kill
a bunch of the pests but the resistant
members and there are always some
mutations that give resistance
they're going to explode their
population will explode and you and your
tool will be gone it won't work anymore
but if you merely discombobulate
your
predator
your past
confuse it
which psychedelics and other drugs do uh
make it lose its appetite which most
drugs do
um you're much better off because it
won't it won't have this kind of
selective pressure
so
i got this insight from my cat frank
who
um had a real issue with catnip i had a
catnip plant in my garden and my garden
was fenced
and every night when i was going out to
the garden to pick something for dinner
frank would follow me
and look up at me and he wanted to be
shown where the catnip was and i would
show him to the catnip and he would roll
in it and get really
stoned
and um and then forget where he had seen
the catnip and he had to be reminded
every single day this is an intelligent
cat like where was that plant
the plant had drugged him so that he
would lose track of where it was
oh wow so i thought that was a pretty
clever plan certainly more clever than
frank was
speaking of clever plants then
transition yeah that wasn't bad was it
um
i on the topic of psychedelics which i
referenced at the start
when i first heard about the concept of
psychedelics i like you because i've
heard you talk about your initial sort
of perception of them
was terrified by the thought of losing
my consciousness i also thought as you
know you talked about cancer anxiety in
your writing and how patience with
suffering with cancer i think the last
thing i'd want to do is trip if i had
yeah cancer but also another point that
you made in in a talk you you gave was i
saw myself as a very logical scientific
physical person and i thought that i
couldn't be that and
spiritual or however you want to
describe it or really anything i
couldn't think or feel
tell me about your journey then from
going from that place
to psychedelics i i know it's well
documented in
the journey you've taken but i but i
really want to understand how your
perception shifted and where it sits
today as a spiritual
individual
so i did see myself as a very
materialist uh in my philosophy um
i thought that the laws of nature we
knew explained everything and anything
else was supernatural you know and i'd
talk to a lot of people who done
psychedelics and had this big spiritual
experience and so i was curious about it
because i did i i said somewhere that i
thought i was kind of spiritually
[ __ ] i just it was a part of myself
i hadn't developed
and but i did have this misconception
that uh to be spiritual is to believe in
supernatural things yeah okay and that's
kind of a scientific view it's something
you know scientists assume this about
spiritual people
i had a couple big experiences on
psilocybin
as i was uh researching the book more
immersive journalism and um nice excuse
i know i you know i did feel
i was curious to try these things but i
also felt compelled i think my readers
expect me to do stuff you know that i'm
writing about and not just be on the
sidelines and so i did feel some real
pressure to do it but i was i did these
conversations with volunteers in these
studies and individuals who had you know
amazing experiences that completely
changed their attitude toward death i
mean people who who lost their fear of
death
after one four hour experience on
psilocybin i mean how does that happen
you i mean you you have to be curious
about that
um psilocybin being the active
ingredient in magic mushrooms yeah um
but in these trials they get it in a
pill form it's kind of purified but it's
the same same drug exactly
so
i had a couple really interesting
experiences
that reset my understanding of what
spiritual meant
and
my experiences had to do with powerful
connection to something bigger than me
that i felt
um specifically for me it was the plants
in my garden
that i mean i'm a gardener i've been
writing about plants one way or another
for a long time
and i've always admired plants and i
think you know as we were talking about
the the the citrus plants with the
caffeine i think they're really
intelligent um in a very different way
than we are
but it was that was kind of an
intellectual conceit i didn't feel them
as
conscious beings
and during this trip i did i was in my
garden and all the plants were like
talking to me i mean not literally
talking to me but they were returning my
gaze they were present they had a
sentience
um
and it was and they were very benign
they they liked me
i took care of them you know i
fertilized them um but it was a very
powerful connection to nature that i
hadn't felt before most of us when we
walk through the natural world we we
sort of feel we're sort of part of
nature but we're sort of not part of
nature we're all alienated from nature
that's our human thing and it's our
human arrogance actually but um
but it's also a failure of imagination
to see ourselves as animals and but
that's what we are
we're a little different and in their
ways in which we have transcended nature
or think we have but anyway
i felt more
one creature among many than i had ever
felt in my life i was just another
creature in the garden and and it was
kind of liberating it was this wonderful
feeling it was it was a great moment
so i had that experience and then i had
another experience of uh you know what
people call ego death of you know total
ego dissolution on a high dose
psilocybin a guided psilocybin trip it's
not something you want to try on your
own
and
i saw myself kind of explode in a cloud
of post-it notes blue post-it notes and
then they fell to the ground and there i
was this this
pool of paint on the ground and that was
me
but i was observing it from this new
perspective
that was completely untroubled by what
should have been a catastrophe
and
it was fine this is how things are and
then having no ego anymore
i had no walls and i just merged into
this piece of music that the guide was
playing this bach unaccompanied cello
suite um
that was
indescribably beautiful and i but there
was no subject-object relationship i
just became the music i just joined it
it was the most profound experience
listening to music i'd ever had
so
i came out of these experiences like
rethinking what is spiritual mean
and i came to understand it it means
having a profound connection with
something larger than you um it's a kind
of love
it's um
it could you know some people have it
with the universe i had it with the
plants in my garden
and this piece of music
[Music]
and
that
that sense of profound connection that's
what i think of as spiritual now
and there's nothing
there's nothing supernatural about it
you could say well your plants weren't
really conscious
but they are sentient beings and
we're the first culture in history
that's forgotten that you know our
scientific world view
has given us this incredible blind spot
about the sentience all around us you
know going back to descartes um
who you know thought that we were the
only thinking creature and and
no other creature felt pain or had
consciousness um
and most of us still sort of believe
that i think even though we're learning
that sentience goes way down um and that
i just read a paper saying that insects
may have consciousness
wrap your head around that um
christ
that well there are a lot of ethical
there are a lot of ethical implications
um
so so my point is though that
the perception that you're surrounded by
sentient beings is not supernatural we
are
and
what the um psychedelics are removing is
this is this filter that's allowed us to
see things in this very narrow
materialist scientific
world view paper was published uh just
this week
by the group at johns hopkins roland
griffith was the author he's the guy i
was just telling you about who studies
both caffeine and psilocybin
and they they did a big uh observational
study of people who've had a psychedelic
experience to see if
their uh how their beliefs changed and
they and the thing they looked at was
really interesting they looked at
attribution of consciousness to other
beings
um
and it went up dramatically um so people
who
i think normally 13 of people think
plants have some consciousness it went
up to like 58
and that was the most dramatic gain but
everything did i mean people attributing
consciousness to animals to cats and
dogs to insects it all went up now you
might think okay psychedelics increases
your magical thinking but they also
checked did you believe in the loch ness
monster and a bunch of other kind of
magical nature things
and they didn't there was no change
there
but this attribution of consciousness
went way up across the board
and so what does that tell us well
every traditional culture has believed
that there are many species that are
conscious that are sentient um and that
um this is something we've unlearned
and i think
one way to interpret is psychedelics
um
you know unlearns the unlearning
basically and and it allows us to
see something that all children see
and most traditional people see
which is the fact that we're not the
only thinking
being um so
that's just that's a spiritual question
too
i my first real experience with the
psychedelic was san pedro actually the
cactus yeah yeah really interesting
experience so i drunk this drink
um with my partner and where were you
okay i don't think it grows that well in
england no
yeah you can grow it out here yeah well
yeah i i've heard but but it was a
really interesting experience like first
two to three hours
the guy the shaman takes it to a cave
because it's raining and nothing i'm sat
there for three hours nothing
i leave the cave and i go back out into
the hills the beautiful sort of grassy
hills with trees and everything and the
minute i got outside i think within two
minutes i was convinced i've said it to
my team before i was convinced that me
and the plants
were the same thing and really that they
were like they were like looking at me
i was looking at them and they were like
looking at me and it was the first time
i felt like i had as you describe it
a almost human relationship even with
the the grassy hills but it was really
these plants in front of me it was like
they were an audience now were they the
characters
they were just they were just these
these tall plants
and it felt like they were like looking
at me and trying to tell me something
and you're right the experience i had
was i totally
didn't matter in the same way that i'd
mattered three hours ago my all sort of
sense of self importance had had gone
and i was just as important as this this
little plant and it was and as you
describe it it was we were the same
thing and i was in awe of that that
feeling
obviously you don't forget the feeling
you don't forget the memory but you
almost you lose the feeling a little bit
you do i think you do i think you go
back to baseline to some extent not
completely um
i i i
i don't know i find that i can
return to some of those ways of thinking
so my involvement with psychedelics led
to a meditation practice
and um i think psychedelics are very
good for starting a meditation practice
um
i could never do it
you know i was i was just a very
frustrated meditator before that when i
tried and um
but i'd had certain kind of paths of
consciousness laid down during the
psychedelic experience that i could get
on again
not so much the peak experience you know
the fireworks um and that's what people
end up talking about or writing about
but a lot of the psychedelic experience
is this long tail this long dana mall
uh as you're coming down you're
regaining control over what you're
thinking about you can direct your
attention here or there yet you're not
distractible you are really
in a zone
and
that state is a meditative state and
having laid down those tracks you can
get back to them i think um with work
and sometimes it's a matter of thinking
about an image i saw on a psychedelic
trip that helps me get there
so
i think that's one way you keep it alive
um because psychedelics aren't a
practice you just you can't do it that
often you don't want to do it that often
it takes a toll it's hard work um and
that's one of the reasons that i think
they're not habit-forming and they're
not is that after a big psychedelic trip
you're not saying when can i do it again
you're saying do i ever have to do it
again and um because it's hard work and
it can be overwhelming
but
there is a residue that stays with you
and some people i've you know really
seen their lives turned around and they
have a big uh you know they take away a
lot
i i for me it's been subtler things like
that but i i can use meditation to kind
of
nurture that flame
well one of the you talk there about
people's lives turning around after a
psychedelic experience obviously the the
studies that are being done on
psilocybin and many other psychedelic
compounds um
are pretty profound when you read about
them the the impact of one dose one trip
in the right set and setting on things
like treatment resistant depression are
really like almost hard to believe
yeah and um
and i think we should take them with a
grain of salt i mean i think that one of
the things to understand they're very
impressive results they're much better
than the results for antidepressants
when they when they came on the scene
they were approved with like marginal
utility i think they they scored like
two percentage points better than
placebos
you know but it doesn't take a lot to
get a drug approved
here you're seeing substantial sustained
changes in people um which is great but
it's important to understand the early
studies on any drug tend to be more
positive than they are later
part of the reason is that that the
researchers are optimizing everything
they have very trained well-trained
guides they
they can exclude anyone who's too
depressed or
has some other problems so they're you
know they they're not giving it to
thousands of people they're giving it to
hundreds of people so i think we could
expect as we get to phase three and then
introduction
that the effects won't be quite as good
as they've been but so far they've been
like two-thirds of people in most of
these trials whether it's mdma for
trauma or psilocybin for depression or
addiction
have um you know lost their diagnosis
and that's pretty extraordinary and
we're talking about potential cures not
simply uh symptoms dealing with symptoms
um so it's very exciting research i
think i'm a little concerned about the
kind of irrational exuberance that's
surrounding the space there's all this
investment money there's there's more
capital than there are good ideas i i
would say that's my reading of the
situation um
and people are going to get hurt you
know so i i just see a bubble here that
concerns me but there is something real
here
um
and i just hope we can be careful about
how we you know that we don't
uh build up people's expectations
especially people with mental illness
that they think they've got a cure it
doesn't work for everybody
and and some people have really hard
experiences on psychedelics
that tends to be the case with that sort
of bubble that you described tends to be
the case with all
new industries the internet
cryptocurrencies psychedelics they have
this euphoria bubble and then there's a
flattening where the the tree value
emerges over time especially on silicon
valley which is some like some fashion
conscious money
and because i've seen this you know
having worked in the food space uh
agriculture there was i remember this
moment in 2008 or so uh where all the
silicon valley people were investing in
ethanol they thought this was the gr
this green energy this is turning corn
into fuel
and it was clear to anybody close to the
situation that in fact it took more
energy to make ethanol than you got out
of it it was just a way to get rid of a
surplus of corn on the part of the
farmers and the government but everybody
jumped in bill gates um you know this
the sandhill road crowd and um and you
could watch this and then they very
quickly realized oh this isn't such a
good business and and then then they got
into food and they got into mock meats
and that's where they are now they're in
the food industry as well as
psychedelics and they're going to be
very disappointed at the returns in the
food industry which like if you're lucky
or two or three percent
um it doesn't scale like software
some of the evidence in these clinical
trials does show the efficacy of the
psychedelic psychedelic compounds and
one of the questions i had and i know
that you know you've done a huge amount
of research on this is if psychedelics
are effective even in some cases what
does that say about the causes of these
that's a great question yeah
the honest complete answer is we don't
know
but the best theory that that i've come
across
is that if you look at the different
disorders that psychedelics
appears to be effective in treating
depression anxiety
obsessive-compulsive disorder addiction
all of these are mental disorders that
involve a kind of rigidity of thought
people stuck in loops of rumination
um inflexible thinking they need this
drug to get through the day
um
they have this narrative in their head
that they're a bad person that nothing
is working in their life or
they have anxiety and they replay loops
about you know what makes them anxious
what psychedelics appear to do what
psilocybin appears to do is break those
habits of thought
it's it's kind of a solvent um and so
that it uh shakes things up in a way
that makes the brain more plastic more
able
to learn new patterns because this is
essentially people stuck in old patterns
and so i think that this is probably its
contribution the most beautiful metaphor
of this that i i heard from a
neuroscientist
he said i i think of i think think of
your mind as a hill covered in snow
and uh it would have been a mountain
except he was from holland and they
don't have mountains um and your
thoughts are um sleds going down the
hill
after a while your thoughts are gonna
keep getting drawn like attractors into
the same grooves and it's going to be
very hard to get down the hill without
falling into those grooves
think of the psychedelic experiences in
fresh snowfall
filling the grooves
allowing you to take any path you want
down the hill
so i think it has to do with habitual
thinking
rigid brains stuck brains brains that
have too much order
and need to be disordered a bit
so you know this all remains to be
proven there's actually a uh a group at
uh mass general at harvard
that is looking at the whole question of
rumination in psychedelics and seeing if
that is indeed the common denominator
because we think of all these diagnoses
as
actual real things but they're really
conventions of the psychiatry industry
and if you read the dsm the
the whole encyclopedia of diagnosis
every five years they throw out a bunch
they add a bunch they don't really know
what they're doing
so i remember asking a psychiatrist i
said isn't it a little weird that this
same drug works on these five different
things you know addiction and obsession
and he said well how do you know they're
different things
maybe they're all different symptoms of
the same brain same kind of brain
and so you know
i mean if you if you think about it
anxiety is is worry about the future
depression is really of being a victim
of the past but it's a similar mental
construct
and psychedelics appears to weaken it i
read that that in
that sort of analogy of the hill and i
and it really stayed with me that hill
with the snow this idea that our trauma
or whatever it might be our past
experiences have created these groups
which we just you know slide down every
single day and over and over again and
you talked about previously how um
that's why there might be a case for
doing psychedelics lately
yeah yeah exactly yeah i i do feel i
mean as life goes on we become more
creatures of a habit i mean it's just a
given
it's about learning we learn what works
we learn the algorithms that get us
through the day get us through a fight
with our spouse get us through
negotiating with our children whatever
it is we have these algorithms they're
handy they work they save us time and we
are efficient creatures um
but
but habits blind you to
reality you know they they you're one
step removed from experience you're
you're saying okay that's this situation
i'm gonna play this tape
and
you don't you lose your sense of wonder
and that's so important and um and awe
you know was one of the most important
emotions and as we get older you know
kids are have this awe experience every
day every minute you know it could be a
cookie it could be walk down the street
i mean it's just
incredible and the reason is that it's
all new to them and they haven't formed
these habits
and as we get older i think that's where
the value of psychedelics is really
important because they are
reliable awe inducers
and that they
make you see things freshly and um you
know i talk in the book about
this very common
psychedelic insight that love is the
most important thing in the world
and we laugh and it sounds like a
hallmark card and such a cliche but what
is a cliche it's just it's a truth
that's been overused and and and
we protect ourselves with this sense of
irony and banality but love is the most
important thing in the world
so there's truth to that
and that
the line between banality and profundity
is very fine and um
and so
you know you're always hearing people
who have psychedelic experiences and
they come to you with this revelation of
the obvious but we need to be reminded
of the obvious do you think there's
another way to remain fresh in the mind
other than needing to do a psychedelic
trip because i i even relate i'm 29 but
i relate to me getting stuck in the same
patterns of thought which can divulge
into like a bitterness or like they can
so you know some of the some of my
patterns and habits result in happiness
and fulfillment and feelings of
contentment and then other others can
result in like bitterness and resentment
and other negative things so i'd love to
be able to
do some a fresh fall of snow on
something yes i know i know and without
using psychedelics
i mean
learning something new doing something
new is incredibly um revitalizing travel
is i mean think of think of like
how
when you travel somewhere you're in a
new country you've never been there
all your algorithms fail
like
you know
the menu is
full of unexpected things um walking
down the street you don't see the same
brand names you see everywhere you
you're so your senses are are really
working hard because you're taking lots
of new information that's why it's so
exhausting but it's it's so wonderful
too so i think travel is one thing i
think learning a new skill um
you know i think that for me that's
really important it's what i love about
journalism you know i get paid as an
adult to learn whole new fields you know
i'm getting paid now to learn about
neuroscience and consciousness that's so
great
um yes but you know
and and some jobs don't allow you to do
that that is in the nature of journalism
it's the nature of what you do you get
to talk to anybody
so before i ask the question i was
thinking i i was thinking if i was to
answer it myself it's this yeah because
when i walk away from these
conversations
i it's almost like sometimes a
psychedelic trip or just a real shaking
of what i thought to be true yeah and it
and it yeah oh i get that after i do an
interview i you know i i i i came from
an interview with this neuroscientist
and it was like so exciting like to
think about i hadn't thought about
things that way and um
so i think putting in yourself in
situations where there's a lot of new
information and you're out of your
comfort zone the comfort zone is the
problem right and um
if you can put yourself in a situation
and
and also
you know we we tend to gravitate to what
we do well yeah we get reward for that
but you know try working on saying you
don't do well you know i was just
thinking then about how when people get
older they tend to go on holidays to the
same places yes when probably young they
go to somewhere new they don't yeah they
don't want to repeat themselves yeah no
it's true i know it's so i found this
at this phase of life um
the psychedelic experience was really
valuable for that reason um that it did
cause me to rethink things have new
perspectives
and have this wonderful feeling of awe
and be reminded of these things how much
i love plants how much i love love
relationships i mean the sense of
gratitude um that i i've i mean this is
a very common emotion for me and after
in a psychedelic trip is gratitude for
my parents and my son and and my wife
and and um
uh you know i mean we're
we don't we don't spend nearly enough
time expressing gratitude for what we
have we take it for granted
and undermining the taken for granted i
think is the most important thing that
they do
breath work
something i've heard you talk about as
well
yeah so breath work is a
non-pharmacological
mode of uh changing consciousness it was
developed by stan groff a sec a czech
psychiatrist who who worked in the
states for many years
yeah stan's wonderful and i interviewed
him for how to change your mind and
um so when lsd was banned in 1970 uh
he won he was having such good luck with
it and really believed that there were
these new you know
super highways to the unconscious
that he wanted to figure out another way
to induce this state and so he studied
yogic breathing and all these
other traditional uh cultures that have
these trans-induced trans and it's a
pattern of breathing that you do
accompanied by usually rhythmic drumming
that
for i think about two-thirds of people
will put you in a trance state that's
very much like a psychedelic state it
was really eerie how it works um
you
basically
find yourself losing control of your
limbs i mean it's very physical yes
you're on your back and you're dancing
and you're
and you're breathing this very unnatural
pattern of a strong exhalation uh
stronger exhalation than inhalation very
fast i think you're hyperventilating i
think that's what you're doing
and um
and i think that that probably we don't
know this yet but that probably is
reducing blood flow to the brain or
oxygen to the brain
and one of the curious things about
psychedelics is not that they're
increasing brain function but they're
decreasing it in certain important areas
including something called the default
mode network
which is the center of the brain that's
very
very important control center of the
brain that is involved with your sense
of self
time travel uh into the past into the
future
uh the narrative self the story you tell
yourself about your life how you fit
everything into the story of who you are
it's
if the if the ego had an address it
would be the default mode network
it may be that starving that of oxygen
gets a similar effect that psychedelics
do um but psychedelics
that's one of the mysteries it's like
we think of all this extra consciousness
we get from psychedelics or expanded
consciousness but it may be that it's
closing down certain things which allow
other things to happen
i did breath work with um with my
partner and my girlfriend in bali she's
training as a breath work
practitioner so how did it go
so again walked in super skeptical this
guy starts telling me a bunch of reasons
why it's gonna you know the sort of
physiological reasons why it works
it was about 13 minute 20 minute session
i mean
10 minutes i didn't even notice i only
noticed on photos after that i was
laying on my back but my hands were in
the air so and i didn't even i did not
put my hands in there yeah it's
involuntary yeah and they were in the
air for 15 minutes and it didn't hurt my
muscles
and the other thing was i
i went to this strange emotional place
where i felt a huge amount of gratitude
for certain people in my life and i
actually felt the need to like apologize
for recent behavior that i'd carried out
it just
um
it was a very emotional experience um as
it is for i know a lot of people but it
just really compelled me the thought
that doing something with my breathing i
know could have such a profound impact
and then it got me thinking about my
day-to-day breathing which is part of
the
the education about how we breathe so
shallowly right and especially when i'm
anxious
if i'm ever anxious and i think about it
i'm i'm i'm breathing yeah very
20 of what i usually breathe so one of
my ways now if i do feel anxious of
counteracting that from that breathwork
session
is taking seven second inhalation
holding it and then seven seconds and
honestly doing that for 20 seconds or 30
seconds completely seems to flush out
any feelings of anxiousness there's a
bunch of really interesting breathing
exercises there's one that andrew weil
does called
four three
seven four three eight
and it involves a certain amount of i'm
not gonna remember right now but certain
amount of inhalation
hold your breath and then
exhale for longer than you inhaled
and um it's it's remarkable i've done it
before going on stage and things like
that it just lowers your stress level
very quickly i'm guessing it lowers your
blood pressure
there's a lot we don't know about breath
i mean breath is amazing and um uh i i
think you can do a lot to
fiddle with your consciousness using
breath
genuinely of all the things that people
have prescribed or told me the simplest
thing that i've i've
sort of implemented my own life when in
situations where i'm feeling stressed
before going on stage as well before my
tour i used to do it in the green room
or when i'm feeling anxious or over
divulging and sort of like overthinking
is just focusing on my breath
my next question to you my last question
really is is about what's next for you
as a as a tremendously successful author
that's written about such a diverse
range of topics
i mean i think the first question when
you walked in the door was what are you
writing about next yeah it's going to be
something of deep interest you're going
to immerse yourself you're going to buy
a cow again
i don't know what i'm going to do for
this this topic so i'm researching
consciousness the science and philosophy
and literature of consciousness
you know one of the things that
psychedelics does is raise questions
about consciousness you know i talked to
you at the beginning about questions are
more interesting than answers
it's kind of amazing that we're
conscious i mean you know
we could do all this stuff automatically
but we're not we have this space in our
heads where we see things we we assume
other people have consciousness too but
we can't be sure
and um uh and how does
three pounds of tofu in your you know
between your ears
produce
an experience of uh subjectivity of
quality um it's it's it's one of the
greatest mysteries left um so i'm gonna
explore all of it and see where it takes
me you know again i don't know where i'm
going um but that's the that's the
exciting part of
writing
quick one we bring in eight people a
month to watch these conversations live
here in the studio when we're here in
the uk and when we're in la if you want
to be one of those people all you've got
to do is hit subscribe
you know you said at the start that your
job is to answer questions what is the
question that you're trying to answer in
your next project is it just what
consciousness is yes what is
consciousness uh there there's a couple
questions under that though um why do we
have it do we what do we need it for
what does it allow us to do
um
uh
who else has it you know if you look you
know
do the insects have consciousness do the
plants have kind they're people who
believe plants are conscious are they
how do you define consciousness there's
so many subsidiary questions you have to
answer to get to the bottom of it
um
and i think it has a lot of this
question of who else has consciousness
has a lot of um political or
environmental implications
i think that one of the reasons we got
into such trouble with the environment
is the scientific world view for all its
power has blinded us to the
cel the interests of other creatures and
um uh
one of the
you know you look at native american
culture and there's this sense that
everything is alive everything has a
spirit to it
that keeps you from doing something to
certain things to those others right i
mean that you're violating spirits we
don't have that feeling i mean
our worldview allows us to see nature as
something for us to exploit um rather as
our relatives as native americans would
describe it so
so getting consciousness right means
getting a lot of things right um so
wish me good luck no idea i'm sure
you're going to do an unbelievable job
on that because you always have on your
on your on your work and all the books
you've written take a a different
approach and i think that yeah you
highlighted how that comes from a place
starts with from a place of naivety and
curiosity i'm definitely naive i mean
because i have to learn neuroscience for
this a lot of it and and that's a
struggle for me and some of these
theories are really mathematical and
that's really a struggle for me um but
you know that's that's the job is
finding the good explainers who can help
me to explain it and make it i i get a
lot of satisfaction from taking a
subject that people think might be very
dry and difficult and and helping people
make sense of it you know that there's a
tradition on this podcast where the
previous guest writes a question for the
next guest they don't know who they're
writing it for the question is
as you've juggled your life work
relationships friendships and self-time
what things have been key to building
your resilience
doing new things
including taking psychedelics which has
definitely uh
affected me and and
contributed to my resilience
but i i think it's seeking out new
projects and
doing things that break you out of
habitual ways of thinking and responding
to things
habit is wonderful it's very efficient
but it's deadening too
so i'm often thinking and i i am a
creature of habit i have like a whole
routine every day to get myself to the
desk to write but
but breaking it is is uh i think
breaking habits i would say would be an
important one you've spoken to that
throughout this conversation so that's a
beautiful ending this is the side of
leaving your comfort zones as well thank
you thank you for um all the work you're
doing it's really inspiring to me that
an author could be so powerful
and um i i hope we can have another
conversation again once your book about
consciousness is out because i'm sure
it'll be i'll look forward to that it's
been a great pleasure talking to you
thank you michael thank you
i had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast as the seasons
have begun to change so has my diet and
um
right now i'm going to be completely
honest with you i'm starting to think a
lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 of the
time so i track it with 10 of my friends
in a whatsapp group and this tracker
online that we all use together and so
one of the things i'm doing now to
reduce my calorie intake and trying to
get back to being nutritionally complete
and all i eat is i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
[Music]
you